طريقه الحرير هذا يدل دلا قاطعه على وجود
هذا ال هذا التواصل اللحضاري والتجاريه
في تلك الازمنه انه في تاجر صيني او هندي
يدخل من نجران من بوابه نجران الجنوبيه
واقطع اول البحر او من البحر مثلا من
الطريق البحري
ويعالج امور تجارته بما يعني ذلك من
علاقات مع العناصر المحليه والسكان
المحليه هل هذا الصوره صحيح
لو لم تكن موجوده الى ما صدر قانون
القتباني بمنعه غير القتباني الاجنبي الله
يتعامل موجود هذا همم هذا النوع من
التجاره كانت الممالك في جنوب الجزء
العربيه تاخذ هو في شرقها شرق الجزيره
تاخذ البضائع من التاجر الصيني من التاجر
الهندي من المنتج الهندي والصيني ثم تصدر
عن طريق الى الى سوريا والى العراق والى
مصر رئيس
ما انا نعم هي كانت حصلت وصل وفي حلقه وصل
لا شك لكن كانت ايضا منتجا يعني على سبيل
المثال همم لو وجدنا الفخار التيمائي او
الفخار النبطي هذه هذا انواع من الفخار
المتميز
طلعت على الفخار التيمائي ليعود الى 3000
سنه قبل الميلاد واستمر استخدامه الى 700
قبل الميلاد يعني في تعقيدات تحتاج انك
تقوم باعداد بطريقه همم تبغى همم شخص
متفرغ شخص مبدع حتى يستطيع ان يرسم على كل
قطعه فخاريه هذا الرسم الموجود وهذه
الرسوم الهندسيه او النباتيه او الحيوانيه
او الادبيه الموجوده على هذه الجزر نجدها
نجدها اليوم بل تخيل انه في نقش من النقوش
الموجوده عندنا في ديداء في ديدان ان ال-
همم احد همم المكعبات رسمه يعني صممه صممه
سمى ما هو شخص وقام بتنفيذه شخص اخر مكتوب
اسمه فلان ص ما هذا الشكل وفلان يعني قامت
بتاديه هذا الشكل واخراجك منتج فلفل
الجزيره العربيه همم يعني همم هي لا شك
كانت يغلب عليها طابع التواصل الحضاري
ونقل ال ال البضائع وغيرها لكن ايضا كانت
يعني وتنتج منتجاتها لا شك في ذلك لا ولو
لم تكن كذلك لا ما انتجت هذا الكم الكبير
من اللغات والكتابات التي انتشرت في جميع
انحاء العالم فيما بعد خط الثمودي على
سبيل المثال التي تجده في سوريا وفي
العراق وفي مصر وتجد ايضا في ايطاليا وفي
اليونان